you know what it is I love about being  spider-man everything  Peter Parker their husband it's been 10  years  we're giving up too I do some web design  or just the wrist just on the wrist  buddy Peter you're gonna wanna see list  Oscar had you under surveillance  why isn't that question of the day  nothing is what I thought it was I want  to talk to that secrets have cost  my name is Richard Parker I have  discovered what Oscorp postmen to use my  research for  we have plans for you Peter Parker you  wanted to be the hero we can change the  world unless I catch a spider  I made a choice  this is bigger than you I'm the only one  who can stop them  I'm spider-man  I gotta go I'm coming with you whoo I'm  is too dangerous okay sorry I love you  don't hang me  you